as you prepare to sit down with family
and friends for Thanksgiving dinners
Americans are being warned to stay away
from all romaine lettuce everywhere over
new health concerns the CDC says the
leafy vegetable is connected to e.coli
to an outbreak that's made at least 32
people sick in 11 different states 13
people have already been hospitalized
Aaron Warner's at a New York supermarket
where the lettuce has already been
removed and a good morning good morning
Gail and you can see that these shelves
that used to hold romaine lettuce are
now empty
that's because investigators looking
into this ecoli outbreak want stores to
stop selling it and they want consumers
to avoid eating it entirely workers at
New York's Mercedes House Market wasted
no time pulling all the romaine lettuce
off store shelves Tuesday and putting it
into a refrigerator so customers could
not buy it it's very strange for it to
be this type of an outbreak of this size
right around Thanksgiving a lot for ax
is the store's owner it's disappointing
but hopefully we're able to get back on
the Shelf soon the CDC says 32 people
have gotten sick from a potentially
lethal strain of E coli bacteria since
October apparently from eating romaine
lettuce until the source of the tainted
lettuce is tracked down consumers should
avoid all forms of Romain says CDC
epidemiologist Laura Jarrett aus key
don't buy any romaine lettuce and that
includes salad mixes that could contain
romaine lettuce or whole heads or
chopped romaine related illnesses have
now been reported in California the
Midwest and Northeast eighteen cases
have also cropped up in Canada
health officials say this recent
outbreak is not related to one this past
April which killed five people and was
traced to romaine grown in Yuma Arizona
instead the bacteria appears similar to
the e.coli strain that caused another
outbreak last year food safety experts
and reskin worries there may be a
systemic problem with the way romaine
lettuce is grown or harvested is it
coming from the soil is it the water
that's used to irrigate there are any
number of potential sources for
contamination
now if you have romaine lettuce it is
not good enough to just wash it because
the e.coli can be inside the lettuce in
fact they'll tell you how authorities
now that if you have any romaine lettuce
throw it out get rid of it do not eat it
and they recommend that you also
afterwards disinfect your refrigerator
beyond it's not something to play around
with yeah this is serious throw it out
if it's in your fridge Anna thank you so
much